depuis quelques années les factures de
téléphone ont baissé on peut remercier
la concurrence entre les opérateurs même
si sur les portables on aimerait bien
qu'elle soit un peu plus sauvage mais
certains consommateurs ont choisi une
troisième voie le téléphone par internet
et cela peut même être gratuits un
cadeau en quelque sorte avec votre
abonnement internet était fan despinoy
yann richard ici le fou rire et gratuit
ou presque nous ne sommes pas dans un
laboratoire de langues
ida est juste en train de passer un coup
de fil à sa famille en hongrie un coup
de fil sans téléphone la conversation
passe par l'ordinateur et ça coûte 0
lourd fois par semaine et encore
maintenant j'appelle tous les jours des
heures et puis à facture de février 2004
j'avais une facture de 161 en
contournant france télécom cette facture
a maintenant été divisée par 3 justement
hier autant dire qu'elle n'a plus une
minute à elle la recette pour téléphoner
gratuitement partout dans le monde c'est
de charger un logiciel le plus connu
c'est skype bien sûr il y à deux
conditions être déjà sur internet à haut
débit et il faut que votre interlocuteur
soit aussi sur skype est présent
derrière son pc même si elle téléphone
via internet
ida n'a pas pour autant mis au grenier
son téléphone fixe plus pratique pour
les appels locaux
c'est donc une révolution douce pour les
opérateurs si sûr que la partie
téléphonie va devenir de moins en moins
important dans nos revenus
en revanche les revenus de prestations
de services dans lesquels vous avez
l'accès internet dans lesquels vous avez
l'accès haut débit dans lesquelles vous
avez l'accès à la télévision sur adsl va
devenir de plus en plus important en
résumé ce qui va être perdue d'un côté
sera gagnée de l'autre pour le
consommateur en tout cas le téléphone
via internet est bon pour le
porte-monnaie comme si une technologie
qui amène les cours
dimanche à 0 il peut s'attendre à ce que
le prix de la téléphonie de tende vers
zéro le problème pour le consommateur il
est double d'abord que tout le monde
puisse y accéder
qui n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui et
deuxièmement la qualité de service parce
que du coup la qualité de la relation
téléphonique défendu davis l'internet
fort de son succès skype a fait des
petits en france wingo a été lancé en
avril et ce n'est que le début de la
bataille actuellement 30 millions
d'internautes téléphone via leur
ordinateur ils seront 200 millions en